[Music]
some obligations arise from consent if I
hire someone to paint my house and he
does so I'm obligated to pay but can
obligations also arise without an act of
consent consider this story about the
18th century Scottish philosopher David
Hume Hume owned a house in Admiral he
rented it to his friend James Boswell
who in turn sublet it to a subtenant the
subtenant decided that the house needed
some repairs
he hired a contractor to do the work
without consulting Hume the contractor
made the repairs and sent the bill to
Hume Hume refused to pay on the grounds
that he had not consented
he hadn't hired the contractor the case
went to court the contractor
acknowledged that Hume had not consented
but the house needed the repairs and he
had proof London the court ruled in the
contractors favor and required Hume to
pay him put aside whatever the law might
have been at the time how would you have
decided the case from a moral point of
view do you think that Hume is morally
obligated to pay this contract him
[Music]